what's up Brandon slipped Theo just got
done running little green way here in
Smithfield North Carolina I got a a
debate club for you so when you go
running you're gonna put your keys and
phone and your wallet all up in your
your pants and your pockets be that be
that bulgy pocket bozo or you won't make
them honey's drip drip when you put it
all in you panty-dropping poom pop in
the fanny pack what was gonna be boys in
a pack of puppies he did it
Gang Gang buzzbuzz buzzbuzz young Thor
good one dude that was a nice running
you know he got through it but it's a
struggle a little bit got a little buddy
there plan a pop pop pop drip robbery
robbery Denver sad [ __ ]
I can't I you know how some people have
OCD my OC I can't have things in my
pocket if you notice whenever I sit down
so look at all the [ __ ] I have out I
always leave a [ __ ] out and then when I
ride my bike think boy bike club I got a
fanny pack we're gonna do think my fanny
packs that fanny pack what school put
jeez put my nicotine in there I'll get
the gel packs put my cell phone cords
and you hit them trails
hey let's seem like fun alright here's
what I do I do something that a normal
person knows I hide my keys in the woods
near where I park you [ __ ] gets stolen
huh no I lost my shoe your Jeep I did
lose my keys actually once in Baton
Rouge I hit him
but usually I put them in the tire well
or I'll put them in the woods nearby
underlie come on stupid [ __ ] man do you
do that before you park it
chuck-e-cheese no dude I'm not running
with a bunch of keys on me dude like I'm
a janitor and a fire bro get a fanny
pack dude I'm not getting that all right
we do that Marilyn - when we left the
house we just find a bokken stove
and just put our keys in there Kalin did
that make that stolen just a few weeks
ago really yeah he left that bit left
the keys in the car some dude from
Venice man oh cool look at this gay
Prius and then stole it and then counter
found it had crack pipes he found a bum
sleep in the back no way so learn from
town's mistake Oh probably would take
forever to do that long enough from his
mistake this one would you rather use
for a jog pockets pockets is crazy
anybody that wants a bunch of stuff on
[ __ ] man yeah Danika pockets one fifty
three percent set pockets people are too
scared or like gay listen dude fanny
packs they're not gay it's a movement
man yeah see but if you're a girl you
can put it in your chest pocket put your
mom of that titty titty pocket yep tip
pocket a little tip man yeah everything
yeah and what if you have big enough
boobs
sometimes the flat-chested hoes can do
it can hide anything in there really
yeah do you do they do people jog in
Ireland it doesn't seem all and we run
in the rain does the wrong body feels
really yeah that's insane he's finished
last and Olympics it's like you guys in
like Sudan yeah even tight you superior
if you watch Tyson Fury workout it's
like he's working out in his living room
but he's from Manchester right yeah but
he's not like Irish roots I think but
it's herb dinosaur bad will eat so many
potatoes and just drink potatoes Jameson
were like chunky we work out a lot to
get skinny I used to be fast how fat
like chubby kid give me weight how Paul
you like six - okay I used to be like
you'd know I had a big fat face he's
singing one time on TV and I came home
my gran was like yeah you're too fast
that's fair only feedback yeah well
welcome to my Instagram
you go running [ __ ] you know Jim was
almost 300 pounds yeah like Shane is
good yeah Oh fat shaming works yeah what
did was wrong with your [ __ ] face I'm
like yeah no down yeah
may you steals line you got stung by a
bunch of bees somehow steel that's the
answer
yeah it's not a bee sting started yeah I
called you the rat king from Teenage
Mutant Ninja Turtles and here we are
welcome the show mark have you brought
up beyond the arc yet for Theo's look
like oh yeah well brought up their
debate club so be with pockets that's
[ __ ] insane dude I only noticed -
speaking of pockets when Brendan emptied
his he carries loose mints loose mitts
nicotine pouches dude the nicotine very
alarming yeah
[Music]
the king nothing
[Music]